foreign
[Music]
right after Will Smith assaulted Chris
Rock on stage at the Oscars at the
behest of his emotionally abusive wife
Legions of apologists on social media
came up with a brilliant excuse in the
form of a what about ism
they declared that criticism of Smith
and his eventual banishment from the
academy
was hypocritical was even racist because
John Wayne assaulted a Native American
woman on stage at the Oscars and never
faced any backlash now that claim dates
back to 1973 when a woman named sasheen
littlefeather took the stage in her buck
skin dress and Indian get up to uh turn
down the Oscar on behalf of Marlon
Brando she explained that Brando
couldn't accept the award for his
performance in The Godfather because of
a long list of grievances having to do
with Hollywood's treatment of Native
Americans uh the complaints went beyond
Hollywood actually went all the way back
to Wounded Knee in 1890. now why a
massacre in South Dakota in the 19th
century would prevent Marlon Brando from
accepting an Oscar in Hollywood in the
20th century was never explained the
greater Point as far as the social media
peanut gallery was concerned
is that John Wayne was never held
accountable for his vicious assault of
the Native American Woman
of course John Wayne didn't assault
anyone on stage a story which grows with
each retelling much like the eight pound
bass I caught last June which was a five
and a half pound bass as recently as
last month is that John Wayne had to be
held back by security because he tried
to rush the stage and assault the woman
like that that was that was that's the
story it was now they say it was assault
before it was he was trying to rush the
stage turns out that the story about him
trying to Russian stage is also an
exaggeration of the original story which
was that John Wayne was fuming backstage
and ranting about how he wanted to go up
there and pull her off the stage but
then he never did and yet that story too
as far as we could tell was also made up
there's no evidence that John Wayne did
anything of note that night
nothing actually happened this is an
urban legend that started to gain steam
back in the 70s and has taken on a new
life in recent years whenever the racial
grievance Peddlers can make use of it
but
the story it turns out is even Faker
than we thought
not only did John Wayne never tried to
assault the Native American Woman
but evidently there never was any Native
American woman to assault in the first
place
as a report in the San Francisco
Chronicle reveals this week only only a
few weeks after her death
sasheen littlefeather
who died earlier in the month
um and had become a prominent Native
American activist after that incident at
the Oscars spoke out about Native
American issues for decades
was not actually Native American
the chronicle reports quote according to
her biological sisters Rosalind Cruz and
Trudy were Landing Little Feather isn't
native at all it's a lie Orlando told me
in an exclusive interview my father who
was uh was was who he was his family
came from Mexico and uh my dad was born
in Oxford
it is a fraud Cruz agreed it's
disgusting to the heritage of the tribal
people and it's just insulting to my
parents
Little Feather sisters both said in
separate interviews that they have no
known Native American slash American
Indian ancestry they identified as
Spanish on their father's side and
insisted their family had no claims to a
tribal identity
quote I mean you're not going to be a
Mexican-American princess or Landy said
of her sister's adoption of a fraudulent
identity you're going to be an American
Indian princess it was more prestigious
to be an American Indian than it was to
be Hispanic in her mind
so this news has been devastating to
those who championed her as an activist
for All Those Years yet it's a great
relief to Elizabeth Warren who is
practically an Apache warrior in
comparison to this woman Elise Warren is
one one set one thousandth Native
American or whatever it was Little
Feather whose real name was Marie Louise
Cruz didn't even have that much uh claim
the article goes on to provide a
possible reason why Cruz decided to play
dress-up quote news coverage of her
burgeoning attempts to make a name for
herself in the entertainment World hint
at a possible reason for assuming a
native identity about four months before
littlefeather appeared at the Oscars on
September 28 1972 legendary Chronicle
columnist herb Kane wrote a piece about
a turn for the worse in her modeling
career quote sashing littlefeather the
Bay Area Indian princess and nine other
tribal Beauties are soar at Hugh Hefner
Playboy ordered pictures of them riding
horseback nude in Woodside and other
Beauty spots and then Hefner rejected
the shots as not erotic enough
um why do them in the first place well
explain Little Feather everybody says
black is beautiful we want it to show
that red is two like many aspiring
actors this was assuredly not how Little
feather's Dream of stardom was supposed
to go but perhaps it was better than
being ignored
better than being ignored Billy sums it
up doesn't it
it should come as no surprise that even
back in the 70s professional victimhood
was already becoming a lucrative career
I mean that is the decade after all when
the Boomers came of age and they are the
ones who invented the field of uh of the
professional victimhood they created
this industry and the Marcus Marketplace
that demands it
and it's also it also comes as no
surprise that neither this San Francisco
Chronicle order article nor any other
article or commentary in the corporate
media about this fraud actually grapples
with the fundamental question here
and that question is
why is victimhood so profitable why is
it desirable in our culture to be a
victim
how is it that people can establish long
and distinguished careers for themselves
as professional victims
the chronicle comes up with an
individual explanation for Cruz she was
failing as an actress and as a model and
looking for another way to get attention
but they don't widen the lens and look
at the bigger picture because they never
do because they know that if they did
they would see what they do not want to
see namely
that the desire for victimhood is a
culture-wide disease Sashi littlefeather
and Elizabeth Warren and Rachel dollazal
and all the rest of them the many many
many rest of them
didn't come up with this on their own or
in a vacuum it is a societal phenomenon
we are conditioning people to desire
control and power for its own sake and
to attain it in the most shameful
passive aggressive manipulative way
possible
through emotional blackmail and the
exploitation of misplaced sympathies
now of course people in all cultures in
all periods of history have desired
power and control that's part of the
human condition
but there are good and bad reasons for
wanting it and there are good and bad
ways to try and obtain it
in times past whether power was desired
for a good or bad reason most often the
way to achieve it
was through Success Through uh greatness
through achievement
if you wanted to be somebody you had to
do something you had to accomplish
something
now we've created a society where a lack
of accomplishment is an accomplishment
the less you do the more you can claim
you are oppressed
you just need to belong to the right
demographics
and if you don't well that's an easy fix
you can just lie lie about it
that's what the character known as Sashi
littlefeather figured out and many young
people today are discovering the same
thing
and so as it is probably redundant at
this point to cancel a woman who just
died instead I think today we will again
say to all victimhood Merchants that you
are canceled
well I hope you enjoyed that clip from
Matt Walsh show if you did be sure to
subscribe to this YouTube channel and
click the notification button to get
more content like this if you want to
watch or listen to the full show head to
dailywire.com And subscribe today you
can also listen to my podcast on Spotify
Apple podcast or wherever you get your
podcasts